hey youtubers is Charlie so in honor of
Thor's day I guess Jeremy Renner decided
to drop some concept art whether he was
authorized to do so or not this is gonna
be a breakdown just confirming some of
the Captain America Civil War teams if
you didn't get a chance to see the d23
footage that just confirms what some of
the teams are gonna be we got a pretty
good idea just looking at which
characters were fighting other
characters in that footage but but it
wasn't explicit so going out to bat for
Team Ironman there's war machine black
widow vision in black panther now and a
lot of people are upset at the thought
that black panther is gonna side with
Ironman but most of what we've seen in
the behind the scenes footage shows him
helping Winter Soldier and cap so it
looks like he's gonna bounce back and
forth between them and even though the
rumors are saying that spider-man's
gonna be team Ironman I don't think he
appears in this concept footage because
it was done before they had signed the
deal with Sony if there's anything
they're gonna hold back on I would
assume it'd be that first look at
spider-man in his new costume moving on
the team cap we have Hawkeye teeny-tiny
ant-man on his shoulder here Sharon
Carter Falcon and his Red Wing which is
actually a cool Easter egg from the
comics and Winter Soldier of course so
the fun thing about the Red Wing I think
I explained it in my last Captain
America Civil War video in the comics
Falcon has an actual real-life Falcon
that he uses it's called red wing but in
the movie the red wing is gonna be more
of a drone in the shape of a falcon just
like spider-man is missing from that
team Iron Man pic were also missing
Scarlet Witch from these images she's
supposed to be team cap no idea why she
doesn't appear because Elizabeth Olsen
said that she was going to be in the
movie whenever they were promoting age
of Ultron this is actually what her New
Avengers outfit looks like I don't know
if they're gonna tweak this for Captain
America Civil War but as of the end of
age of Ultron this is what it looks like
cap kind of looks like he's wearing the
same costume
Hawkeye gets a new suit a man's costume
looks like it's pretty much gonna be the
same I don't know how much he's gonna
appear in this film but it's possible
like it's been rumored that we're gonna
see a version of Giant Man we'll see him
grow up and be super big Iron Man
totally gets some new armor just like he
does every movie definitely does not
look vibranium yet but I'm curious to
see if he does get a vibranium suit
during the movie vision suit looks a
little bit tweaked but pretty much the
same as age of Ultron in Falcons suit is
supposed to look a little bit shinier
than it did during ant-man but but
relatively the same I'm kind of happy to
see that Sharon Carter is gonna be a
bigger presence in this film because I
feel like she was one of the most wasted
things in Winter Soldier the problem
with a lot of these big Marvel movies is
there's so many characters like this is
Avengers 2.5 pretty much they keep
saying it's still a Captain America film
so just think about Winter Soldier how
much it featured cap versus the other
characters I think for the most part
like the other major characters like
Iron Man we'll see them enough to get
their point of view to understand why it
is they take the position that they take
some other really big characters that
don't appear in this concept footage
general Thunderbolt Ross I know everyone
wants to see Red Hulk but I totally do
not think that we're ready for Red Hulk
yet
Mark Ruffalo was supposed to be like a
small presence I don't think he'll be a
big character but if Thunderbolt Ross
gets involved it probably has something
to do with the Hulk and then Martin
Freeman is kind of like the liaison
between the United Nations in the
Avengers he's kind of like the guy that
the government assigns to deal with all
the superheroes I imagine he's gonna
have some fun dealing with Tony Stark
if Tony Stark is gonna side with the
government and they actually they have
been pushing the idea of the
Registration Act so it sounds like
they're doing something pretty close to
the comic book Civil War Ark the problem
with that is that civil war in the
comics just like Secret Wars it involves
like every single character that Marvel
has in the comics and then they can't do
that on screen so thematically yes this
will be comic books Civil War but just
expect them to tune the characters way
way down to just the IP that they have
access to
spider-man being like the one exception
and remember this isn't gonna be like
iron spider spider-man that was a much
older character this is gonna be 15 year
old spider-man not expecting some crazy
Iron Man tech but I do think the Tony
Stark will try to win him over with some
toys it's especially a new suit so you
guys can let me know like what do you
think about these teams that they've
picked I know it seems weird to put
Black Widow against Hawkeye because they
seemed like such good friends in the
first Avengers film but they're just
another example of like two close
friends cap and Iron Man having like a
huge difference of opinion I think the
real question is is like what pushes
them over the edge on one side of the
other like you can tell that Hawkeye
really cares about his family he wants
his anonymity he wants to live a normal
life and Black Widow seems like maybe in
the wake of what happened with the whole
and Avengers age of Ultron she's like
maybe I can't have a normal life but as
of the end of age of Ultron she was
actually in charge of training the new
Avengers with cap cap is still the
leader of the Avengers but she was kind
of like his co-leader
and what about Scarlet Witch in the
vision that that's just exciting
obviously those characters are brand new
so they haven't export any kind of
relationship between those two but if
you've read the comics then you know
that they're one of the biggest couples
in the Marvel Universe or they have been
in the past but I feel like a lot of the
reason why they picked the teams the way
they did is because they wanted to
balance things like they wanted to feel
like each character on each team had an
opposite on the other team george RR
martin was actually like shaking his
fist at Marvel and a lot of the other
big comic-book movies his complaint is
that he's getting tired of seeing heroes
fight villains with the exact same
powers that's another good argument to
make like do you want to see heroes
fight villains with completely unique
powers that have absolutely nothing to
do with their own powers like Iron Man
in the first Iron Man film fights Iron
Monger just like a bigger version of
Iron Man do you want to see that stop
either way it's time to get high I feel
like Marvel's slowly gonna be rolling up
more and more Civil War stuff in the
next couple of weeks we might get a
trailer in the fall Disney doesn't have
any really big movies in the next month
or so but if they're gonna be posting
new Star Wars footage then they might as
well post new Captain America Civil War
footage too I know a lot of you guys
have been asking for an agents of shield
season 3 video so that's what I'll
probably do for my next Marvel video be
sure to subscribe to get it I'll try to
get it out in the next day or so
I've still got a game of Thrones Q&A to
post just so much awesome stuff happened
today just in case you guys haven't seen
it you can click here for the new Star
Wars footage to just post it it's a
really short clip but it is really
awesome and you can click here for all
my Captain America Civil War videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's have five I'll see you guys
tonight
you